greetings taken I had a feeling you'd be
coming through here sooner or later you
have a knack for going where the killing
is thickest
I Came Upon these refugees on my way
through Smuggler's past they were
trapped and would soon have become food
or entertainment for the trolls I had to
do something
now we're stuck out here caught in the
midst of a battle between the trolls and
the Ethereal forces the tunnel to
Homestead is blocked by Aether fire and
the only option now is a Passage through
the mountain deeps it is a foul place at
the bottom of the world infested with
all manner of terrible things that hate
the Sun
there is no way these people would
survive down there in Devil's Crossing I
saw that you had the power to open Rifts
I need you to fight your way to
homestead secure a rift and come back
for us so please help these people
below is an entrance to the deeps from
there you'll exit onto the dusty road
so how doomed are we now that we come to
it I can't say I'm eager to experience
travel by Rift I hope you know what
you're doing
foreign
[Music]
foreign
but you pulled through those people owe
you their lives I wish that was the end
of our troubles but there was a mounting
threat on the horizon that